[Music]
good morning John it's Tuesday July 3rd
how long am I gonna be on the out days
tired of the on days out on the porch
again on a porch swing so if I look like
I'm constantly moving to you it's
because I'm constantly moving hopefully
that's not gonna make anybody nauseous
and reference to your new nerdfighter
scheme I am just mostly very happy at
the abilities of our current
nerdfighters because damn couldn't
actually keep up with the amazingness of
the nerdfighters brotherhood 2.0 sponsor
a new person in queue org and then by
the time I was done and had gone away to
you know urinate or something I'd come
back and it was already all the way
funded people are really excited about
this idea which I think that they should
be however you're right there could be
more nerdfighters and more nerdfighters
would be a good thing
excited for all you new senior executive
nerdfighters I'm sure we will have
projects for you soon and don't worry if
you've seen more than one episode of
Brotherhood 2.0 you're not really in it
anymore
you're a nerdfighter we'd love it if
you'd comment more and I'd like to see
you in my pants and rating our videos on
YouTube getting nerdfighter tattooed
across your face actually I seem to
remember a point in time when people
were sending us cool little nerdfighter
things that they were doing like one
person's felt nerdfighter on their
knuckles and sent us a picture one
person made an Easter Egg that said
nerdfighters on it I would like to
encourage people to do that more those
made really good middle frames for the
YouTube clip someone said they did
sidewalk chalk nerdfighters in their
driveway advertise yourself as a
nerdfighter do nerdfighters stuff mostly
just with the word nerdfighter and send
it to us and it's extremely likely that
it will be on the show I do have one
other little bit of business to attend
to
you do know what a Decepticon is right
you know you didn't make up that with
septa comes or transformers the enemies
of the Autobots when you chose
Decepticons as a name for a nerdfighters
enemy I initially thought that there
must be some better team of
supervillains to use as our enemies
I looked and I realized that
supervillains don't common teams
supervillains almost always work alone
with henchmen below them and the
Decepticons are kind of a gigantic
exception to that rule I help thinking
of different villains from cartoons from
my childhood dr. claw shredder mom Ross
Skeletor you know people like that but
the Decepticons really are a team of
super villains
I think that's impressive frankly as the
enemy of nerd fighters do operate in
teams they're not on their own they
don't have henchmen
I think Decepticons is so far a pretty
good name for them anyhow I will see you
tomorrow